[Music]
best-selling author john grisham is here
to talk about his new legal thriller the
writer has published 37 books in 33
years both drawing his own experience in
the courtroom as a lawyer in mississippi
his latest the judges list is no
different it's a second book to feature
lacey stoltz let me get my movie voice
on
in a world where a lawyer investigating
complaints against a judge
things take a turn for the worse when
the anonymous source accuses a sitting
judge of being a serial killer i'm glad
you went all the way with that it is
good yeah john grissom joins us right
now good morning john happy to be here
so uh the wife and i were supposed to
start a new show this weekend i opened
page one and i haven't put it down since
it is incredible wow um you're this is
the second book on lacey who is a
complicated character what made you
revisit this character
i have a crush owner uh i created her
six years ago in the whistler
and by the time i finished that book i
really liked her as a person as a lawyer
you know she's a pretty cool character
and i knew i would go back for at least
one more i rarely do that
normally when i'm yeah i finish a book
the
most characters are dead so uh i can't
use them again uh i've gone back you
know with jake brigance and a time to
kill three times now last year was a
time for mercy but normally when i
finish a character i'm done with them
but i really like lacy and i thought i
could do one more story yeah but this is
about a serial killer
a subject that you've never taken on
before and it got me wondering and
worrying about your mental state yeah
because they're so it's so detailed how
this guy works
how did you research this dawn because
it's very chill and i have to say
i was reading the book i got afraid to
turn the page because i was afraid how
it was going to end yeah and i was
worried that you would end it in a way
i'm not going to give it don't spoil the
i'm not i'm definitely i'm definitely
not but it was it was very tough because
i because clearly this character doesn't
mind killing yeah so what did how did
you research it and you know we'd be
worried about you john grisham no don't
worry uh i've never killed anybody i
have no list gail i'm not keeping a list
um
the idea of a serial killer is always
fascinating we have a we have a
fascination with crime in this country
and most of the books i deal with have
written uh crime is uh
is there whether it's wrongful
convictions or death penalty or whatever
those the issues i like to write about
um
there's always a you know a serious
crime involved so i kind of live in that
world what was like planning his crimes
is it fun for you to just
think about if you're a sociopath it's
hard to think like one um all the people
who have wronged you in your life yeah
they think about the people you really
you still carry a grudge i have a couple
i have a couple we all have a couple
okay they show up
don't want to kill them but you know
it'd be fun to watch i don't want to
kill yeah so you take it one step
further and this guy's a you know it's a
serious character a character he wants
he wants to get revenge and so he does
we we do have a fascination with crime
in this country uh we also are obsessed
with justice
uh and sometimes it seems like when
justice is miscarried we're so fixated
on it that we don't correct the issue
you're involved with the innocence
project wrongfully accused and convicted
people how has that work impacted your
work as a legal writer legal thriller
writer
uh tremendously
it began to change 15 years ago when i
did a book called the innocent man which
is my only non-fiction book
that book took me into the
world of wrongful convictions and i i'm
still there
because every wrongful conviction is a
fast a fantastic story some people don't
believe in wrongful convictions they
think you know that the people are there
for a reason
there are many there are many innocent
people there are tens of thousands of
innocent people in prison yeah okay
most people don't believe that
most white people don't believe that
black people know it they've lived
they've seen it okay and racism is a
huge factor in all in almost all
wrongful convictions
uh i'm on the board of the instance
project we had 375
dna exonerations in the past 25 years
70 involve men of color
okay
and so it's 75 yeah so it's it's it's a
huge factor but there there there are
thousands of innocent people in prison
at the innocence project uh we litigate
you know in all 50 states trying to get
our clients out and we
you know we're successful but it's very
hard work we have to get going but real
quick do you miss practicing law never
practice law never never nobody misses
it that was quick
no i didn't
i did it for 10 years in a small town in
mississippi and you know it was it was
uh enjoyable to appoint i got the bug to
write though about halfway through that
career please keep the bug going
the bug is going i don't know if you've
seen all these right here this is real
i'm under contract i have to write it
it's really really really good i'm not
just saying that because you're here it
is we thank you the judges list here it
is thank you is on sale today i'm
holding up the book guys
they don't show it oh there it is it's
on sale today wherever you like to buy
your books you got lots of options john
grisham we thank you again and we'll be
right back always fun guys thank you